for a while now yeah and tomorrow in the  semifinals you're definitely going to  meet a teenager vincent kymer or prague  right now it looks like chimer so what  would you expect from that  if it is the german  yeah um very strong and i was i was lost  against him yesterday so  yeah what's this what's the score in the  match is he plus one he is plus one and  they are now playing game four bar is in  the middle i don't know if you're seeing  the screen if you can give us your  thoughts on the game  yeah it looks a little bit better for um  for white to me at least practically  with uh  with the with the weak king and  the the past pawn  black obviously has trumps as well but  it it feels like  a little bit easier to uh to to play for  white but um  um yeah certainly vincent is a pretty  heavy favorite in the in the match  regardless yeah  interesting to